the internet well really the world can't
get enough of the amber heard and johnny
depp trial it's been filled with
stunning revelations and accusations
the recording we just listened to that's
exactly what happened in australia
mr depp lost the tip of his finger after
you threw a bottle at him isn't that
right who was the real monster in this
relationship misheard lives in johnny
half of johnny i do not know when james
came over okay let's remind you that
have made it must stream court tv he
promised you he would never you would
never see his eyes again isn't that true
you had all of the seven million dollars
for 13 months before mr depp sued you
and you chose not to pay it to the
charities that's the knife you gave to
the man who was hitting you right
misheard but one thing we have to admit
we never saw coming the internet's new
fascination with depp's lawyer camille
vasquez including rumors that the actor
and his attorney are more than friends
camille's even got fans of her own
waiting for hugs after court but it's
moments like this that have the internet
wondering is there more to this
relationship than lawyer client are you
dating johnny depp
it's all over the internet can you set
the record straight
yes or no that's camille pleading the
fifth as she was leaving court on
tuesday but now a source is opening up
to e.t telling us that the rumors that
johnny and camille are dating are 100
unequivocally untrue
and as camille a southwestern law school
graduate who's been practicing since
2017 continues fighting on dep's behalf
one thing's for sure the world will
continue watching i don't think we'll
ever see a case quite like this before i
mean the celebrity factor here
particularly the fan base for johnny
depp is so unique so it's going to be
kind of tough to judge other abuse cases
that have happened or might happen based
on this one but having said that i am
concerned at how cavalier society has
been at dismissing amber heard's
allegations it's disturbing and yes it's
going to give maybe people in the future
pause before they come forward with
allegations against an a-list celebrity
i mean ironically this was the very
thing that amber heard warned about in
her washington post article the article
that johnny depp is suing about that she
came forward and society and culture
went against her
[Music]
you